*gay clapping*
stupid videos
*more gay clapping*
Favorite videos
*Clapping*
*EDM Intro Music*
Hey, welcome
Today we're gonna watch the favorite videos
The yearly show where I watch my favori...
*More EDM Intro*
This is the second year around that we do this
I'm really excited
Let's watch
I think my favorite... this is one of my favorite videos
because even years after I saw this video
I have no fucking clue what this is about.
And if you what they're saying
I don't want you to comment and be like:
"oh no this is a commercial for tampons".
Just don't tell me.
That would ruin the mystery.
But let's watch.
Already this guy is me
*laugh*
*Slow low singing*
What is it about?
I need to know what is it about
Don't tell me what it's about!
But I need to know
what language is that?
Roy kho coupah so
What the fuck does that mean!?
*Bang*
Ouch, shit!
Look at his fucking chin
Look at the chin
I don't know what the product is but I will have ten "roy kho copah sue"
Alright my favorite video number 2
Ahh... won't make any fucking sense either
Especially cause it's a swedish video and it's a famed swedish actor
Jakob Eklund
who says "va fan"
which basically means "what the fuck" or...yeah that's what it means
and... he just likes to say it a lot
It's kinda like the...
*Stuttering*
Let's just watch!
*Swedish*
It's so good
I don't know... ehh...it might just be a swedish thing
I can't tell, let me know
It's just one of my favorite.
It's dear in my heart
I don't what to tell you
Oh, this is a video I like to go back in
you know you watch things and you notice how they've changed.
And this is one of those videos
where you are like: "no, nothing has really changed".
It's Lucas Molyneux, ahh...
made a message to Valve...
Basically Lucas is the son of Peter Molyneux
which is a very famous game developer publisher..
uhh... and his son wants Half-Life 3 to come out
[Kid]: I've been trying to entertain myself with portal and everything
He's been trying to entertain himself with portal and everything
That poor boy
[Kid]: I think you make really good games and stuff and uh.....
I'm gonna have to agree with Lucas Molyneux
that you do make very good games
when you actually make them
Alright, I have weird taste in Youtube videos
Shut up
Just watch what he says next
[Kid]: but I've been waiting so long... [Pewds]: he's been waiting so long for Half-Life 3 to come out
[Kid]: umm...
[Kid]: umm...hint can you tell me where Half-Life 3 is based and...
[Kid]: is the demo out yet?
Is the demo out yet?
He's asking for the demo
*Sad music*
This video was made in 2010
He's still waiting, he's still waiting for Half-Life 3!
I don't... I just don't understand
Just make the game
*News music*
Oh boy
OK, here we go
Just watch.
[Reporter LUL]: Good evening, I'm Ken Bastida. Dana is off tonight, he was murdered and then set on fire while celebrating his birthday.
*laughing* oh, let's just do it again
[Reporter again]: Good evening, I'm Ken Bastida, Dana is off tonight, he was murdered and then set on fire while celebrating his birthday.
*laugh*
I think that's a good excuse to be off from work while... what do you think..
*laughing again*
I wonder if Dana ever returned to work after he got murdered and set on fire
fucking lazy ass Dana what a fucking asshole
[Report LUL]: He was murdered and then set on fire [Pewds]: while celebrating his birthday.
*Reading out what's on screen*
I am dead inside, I have no emotions, I have not been able to have an erection for 52 years
This is also a really good video.
Its someone that did a Disney version of uhhh, cover of Slipknot's "Wait and bleed"
And it just works really well. I really like this one
*music*
[Pewds]: Makes me wanna party
[Singer]: Get your fucking hands in the fucking air!
*music*
*Beep*
[Woman]: Hi, I'm Renata Bliss and I'm your freestyle dance teacher
*Techno music*
*Chuckles*
Again
[Woman]: Hi, I'm Renata Bliss and I'm your freestyle dance teacher
How do you dance like that?? Teach me please, please PLEASE teach me.
[Pewds]: I'm minasha plz
You're minasha plz
Minasha Please
Please satan. NO MORE DANCING
Scientificly accurate uh Ducktales, its a fantastic video
It's an animation of the remake of The Ducktales intro
*music*
Oh its like Slippy.
OHHHKAY. Well thats enough for the PewDiePie channel if you want to check out that video
I recommend it, it's really good video. I know that might seem weird for me to say right after that sentence
But it's a great video uhh. I showed too many song anyway
Oh I loved this video so much. Lets, please I hope you haven't seen this before
Because I wanna be the first one to show you
Bullet Ball
[Marc Griffin]: I quit my job, and I sold all my possessions that I could sell.
[Pewds]: This is basically a show where someone comes up with their idea
in front of a bunch of rich people and if they like the idea they will invest in in the the the idea.
Basically like Kickstarter in front of a bunch of rich people
[Marc Griffin]: My game is going to be an Olympic sport.
[Pewds]: He sold his car, his house and everything he owns because his game is gonna become an Olympic sport.
[Marc]: My name is Marc Griffin and I'm the inventor of Bullet Ball and Bullet Ball Extreme.
[Pewds]: Bullet Ball and Bullet Ball extreme
[Marc]: Bullet Ball is a high caliber table game designed for the 21st century lifestyle.
[Pewds]: The 21st century lifestyle. So its a game on the phone huh. That must be it
Its a board game, oh...
Alright
[Marc]: Just like other sports with international appeal such as Basketball, Soccer AND Ping Pong
[Pewds]: AND Ping pong. Like he's trying to copy ping pong that's whats happening
AND it so happens to be just like ping pong
[Marc]: Okey. The object of the game is to get the ball past your opponent
[Investor]: Okay
[Marc]: By utilizing your forearms and our hands.
[Marc]: Okay
[Marc]: My Point!
[Pewds]: I wonder if it's a rule that he has to say "My Point" after you win.
[Marc]: That's Bullet Ball.
[Investor]: Uhhh. How much have you invested in this.
[Marc]: I had this vision, 26 years ago.
[Investor]: What happened?
[Pewds]: It took him 26 years to make bullet ball...
[Investor]: Marc, 26 years is a really long time
[Marc]: Yes it is
[Investor]: Tell me what you have put into this game over those years.
[Investor]: Where are you now?
*Inhale through teeth*
[Investor]: If you sold everything what do you have now
*nervous laugh*
[Marc]: I have Bullet Ball.
[Pewds]: UHHHHH
[Marc]: Uh, I don't even have a home to go back to so we're staying in my car.
[Pewds]: BULLET BALL
[Investor]: Marc, what would happen if we say no
[Pewds]: NO, no don't say no.
[Pewds]: How could you say no to that face.
[Marc]: This idea is mine, this is my dream come true, it will happen. It was destined to be.
[Investor]: You're not going to make it with this
[Pewds]: OHH
[Marc]: OH, I totally disagree.
[Investor]: It's not gonna happen.
[Marc]: It will happen.
[Investor]: It won't happen.
[Marc]: Im telling you it will happen.
[Pewds]: No Marc
[Investor]: Go get your life back, go get a job
[Marc]: I have my invention. And I'm telling you Bullet Ball is going to be a success.
[Investor]: I think its a dream
[Marc]: It's an incredible game.
[Investor]: Im gonna say no.
[Pewds]: Ughhh
[Investor]: I'm a game inventor. I've invented games, I've sold games.
[Investor]: I'm seriously looking at the gameplay here.
[Pewds]: You're rich. Just just buy one. Just buy one. Buy two. Buy ten.
[Pewds]: Just buy it please.
[Investor]: I'm sorry I have to say no.
[Pewds]: NO. Bullet Ball, BULLET BALL dammit.
[Pewds]: Can we please, can we please create a Kickstarter. For Marc Griffin.
[Pewds]: These heartless bastards rejected his idea. Can we please create a Kickstarter.
I will spend 10 grand just on Bullet Ball, to make it happen. Bullet Ball will happen.
I'm serious, I'm not joking. I WANT BULLET BALL
Bullet Ball will happen. It's gonna be an Olympic sport
I'm so fucking pissed. Disgusting. DISGUSTING
[Cutout Pewds]: That's the end of the video. Thanks for watching.
[Both together]: What's your favourite video, leave a comment down below.
*Outro Music*